Whether you say tomato or tomato, it’s clear
that your accent is a defining feature of
who you are.
Everyone has an accent (heck, even goats have
regional ways of saying BAAH), but what’s
the science behind language acquisition and
does your accent say something about you?
In an American survey, 47% of adults found
British accents to be sophisticated, while
51% thought New York accents were rude; Southern
accents were considered nice but possibly
uneducated, while New England accents were
considered intelligent.
But it turns out that humans have a bias towards
others who sound like them or have the same
accent.
Of course, it’s important to distinguish
between a native language accent and an additional
language accent.
English native language accents depend on
factors such as geographic location and socioeconomic
status.
For example a cockney accent of the working
class London is markedly different than the
Queen’s Received Pronunciation.
However, when it comes to non-native language
accents, things are more complicated.
If you decide to move to Spain and learn Spanish
as an English speaker, you will always speak
with an English accent - even if you remain
their for decades.
After the age of 12, the length of residence
has almost no effect on your accent.
Studies pinpoint the ideal age as 6 years
old, with diminishing ability from that point
forward.
Interestingly, some stroke patients wake with
an accent completely different to their original
voice.
This condition is known as the ‘Foreign
Accent Syndrome’ and results from damage
to the insula region of the brain which is
responsible for language processing.
One integral aspect of language is the phoneme.
Phonemes are the different sound units we
use to make up words - some of which are unique
to different languages.
For example, the phonemes with TH (th and
th) as in words like ‘the’ and ‘thing’
do not exist in German, making it difficult
for German speakers to pronounce these words
properly.
Conversely, there are many phonemes in other
languages that as English speakers we cannot
pronounce or even hear properly.
In a groundbreaking study, 32 American and
32 Japanese six month old babies listened
to a recorder play “la la la” repeatedly.
When the recording switched to “la la ra”
a toy to the side would light up and play
a musical tune.
The babies were primed to understand that
recognizing the difference between “la”
and “ra” lead to an audio-visual reward
and both the American and Japanese 6 month
old babies were able to tell the difference
and anticipate the toy reward when necessary.
But “La” and “ra” are phonemes that
do not exist in the Japanese language.
When this study was replicated with 10-12
month old babies, the Japanese babies could
not tell the difference between these uniquely
English phonemes, showing that a critical
period for recognizing phonemes and brain
development is at merely six months old.
If you try and learn a language, regardless
of your age, synaptic connections are made,
which ultimately create a denser grey matter
and stronger white matter networks.
In fact, those who have grown up in bilingual
households are consistently more sensitive
to subtle language differences compared to
their monolingual counterparts.
Brain scans have shown that bilingual babies
have stronger brain responses in their orbital
and prefrontal cortices, which are areas linked
to focus and problem-solving abilities.
But have you ever wondered why so many people
hate the sound of their own voice?
We break down the science and challenge some
people to come to terms with their own voice
in our AsapTHOUGHT video.
Check it out with the link in the description
And subscriber for more weekly science videos.